[Applause]
it's great to be back in Toronto with so
many outstanding members of our liberal
team they've been true advocates for
their community these last four years
helping us bring about real change for
the middle class and building an economy
that works for everyone
I'm very much looking forward to
continuing the work we've started
together after election day but first we
all have a very important choice to make
on October 21st we get to decide what
kind of future we want to build together
we get to choose the kind of country we
want our kids to grow up
alderman James you cannot Jen on the VFC
you go Vietnam under Stephen Harper keep
our sector lucidity Lee Cooper
telephones up to say they Evie don't be
politically conservative the function
Etta my croissants dear economy ecclesia
now swath across all this alive the end
to son dilution four years ago
Canadians chose a new team with a new
approach a team with a clear vision of
the kind of Canada they wanted to build
Canada that is fairer safer and more
prosperous for all Canadians four years
later we still have a lot of work to do
but we've moved forward from the
policies of the Harper years and we've
bought the record to prove it
poverty is way down unemployment is at
historic lows a job creation is way up
and it's because our team rejected
conservative cuts and austerity because
we chose to put people first we stop
sending child benefit checks to
millionaires so we could send more to
the single pair
working two jobs for the family of five
that still has trouble making ends meet
at the end of the month on any proof
snapshot Donny's partially can eject on
best on is they put that class more yet
you know not markdown soon the earth of
solid British the owner is it is a busy
small so please sit down Donny's
infrastructure cursor swallow the
transport the large mob of that will is
a for infrastructure hisses down to Lima
so son is ABC smokey for enumerating
films television in situ done you can I
take a whole account important shop
devotee pleasure the Canada then I can
already you know I've been on the
campaign trail for a little over a week
now
I've been to every province everywhere I
go I talk about the progress we've made
the solutions we've built and the people
we've helped I talked about the change
we delivered real change but as I stand
here today I think of the thousands of
families who've lost a loved one to gun
violence during those same four years on
the issue of guns one thing I can say is
that not enough has changed don't get me
wrong we did take meaningful steps to
address gun violence Stephen Harper made
it easier to purchase and transfer a
weapon we reversed that we started
requiring firearm retailers to conduct
more extensive background checks
something the Conservative leader plans
to scrap if he's elected but as long as
Canadians are losing their loved ones to
gun violence not enough has changed not
for the teenager who was murdered in
Mississauga on Sunday not for the man
who is shot in Calgary on Monday not for
the parent who buried their child not
for the little brother or sister who's
been left behind in 2017 there were 2500
more victims of gun violence in can
then in 2013 2500 the conservative
leader looks at those numbers and still
thinks it should be easier for people to
buy a gun
he is vowed to gut Canada's gun control
law he wants to loosen restrictions on
assault weapons he wants to scrap
enhanced background checks and he wants
people to be able to buy a gun without
ever even showing their license to own
it gun crime in Canada is on the rise
it's a fact frankly I don't understand
how anyone could look at this alarming
trend and conclude that we need less gun
control but that's for the conservative
leaders to explain to Canadians here's
what we will do to end gun violence we
will ban military-style assault rifles
and start a buyback program for all
military-grade weapons that were legally
purchased
[Applause]
and we will work with the provinces and
territories to enable municipalities to
restrict handguns reelected the Liberal
government will do I'll also tell you
what we won't do we will not bring back
the long gun registry and we will
continue to respect Canadian farmers and
hunters but we know you do not need a
military-grade assault weapon when
designed to kill the largest number of
people in the shortest amount of time to
take down a deer Nalani very real but we
see panda new zoo force at IKEA Daddy
announced funding so a sex
Olivia knows Fabiana over correctly
prevents any dairy co-op or adopted
Aloha
keep a method of suspend Tampa admah
need be a middleman for the zookeeper
Sardarji Berman well Akash
but executives auntie a bottom initial
result appeared me that Mathur veggie
day over mursalin wa solo Papa's are
these are my through Pompeii she could
easily obtain universal legal servitude
that immediately net invalidity language
Casio that you know something on the new
voting lemma so let people speak the
commercials SEO in a vault domicile it's
time to end gun violence in Canada and
that's where a reelected liberal
government will strive to do I've often
said that politics is about people and
on this particular issue
here's the hard truth people are dying
families are grieving communities are
suffering so we're going to do more and
we're going to do better thoughts and
prayers are just not going to cut it the
choice could not be clearer liberals are
for tougher gun laws
conservatives are for weaker
[Applause]
that's the difference between forward
and backwards
that's what choosing forward means I'm
Michelle Zelaya with The Globe and Mail
if you couldn't answer in English and
French that would be appreciated for my
colleagues the vast majority of hand
guns used in crimes in Toronto come from
outside the city in fact the damn fork
and gun came from Saskatchewan the
municipal ban would do little to stop
the flow of these domestic guns into the
city so my question is why aren't the
Liberals willing to have a countrywide
ban on handguns we're moving forward on
an approach that is going to work to
keep our communities safe
we know that banning military-style
assault weapons is an important step in
keeping Canadians safe and strengthening
the safe storage laws for lead film done
handgun owners is going to be extremely
important as well to prevent legally
purchased firearms and handguns from
ending up in criminal hands but we've
also heard very clearly from a number of
cities like Toronto and others who said
that they want more tools to restrict
handguns within their municipalities and
that's why we're going to work with them
and work with provinces and territories
to give them the power to do just that
new mechanism Knoebels when the protégée
the Canadian community the velocities
are massive Saku Saku felon also jobs
report Vania is am de su propio metro
municipality within the restrain is on
the point you serve on the museum
comfortable merciless security operation
is almond ax confess illegal
very public imminent means our own CEO
Tanja the freesia on the dr. ho to Amaya
he would add about presidency for
restraint on his own the point is
openness our Ankara he Baker yeah Becky
prevention telecoil Paul L don't need is
cheap affair exactly Massa Tom Perry
with CBC News need to answer in English
and French as well there are already
strict limits on who can own an ar-15 or
a weapon like that there are limits on
the size of the magazine you can have
for this weapon so what's the
justification for banning it outright
and on your buyback program what happens
if someone doesn't want to sell you that
weapon are you not turning law-abiding
gun owners into criminals um we
recognize that there's always going to
be more to do on protecting citizens and
communities from gun violence that's why
for moving forward on banning assault
weapons and enabling cities Japan to
restrict handguns we believe that the
choice is very clear liberals want to
strengthen gun control conservatives
want to weaken it conservative leader
has talked about expanding the size of
magazines available we think that's a
step in exactly the wrong direction the
conservatives want to loosen gun laws we
want to strengthen you know that gun is
designed for killing the largest amount
of people in the shortest amount of time
have no place in Canadian society have
no place in our communities
[Applause]
simple a mile isn't the point P
hopefully sister will support any boy I
wanna build on our wall Pahlavi on
national Saskatchewan give me a fan
shoes yet these circumstances a Danford
fuqua implement listen tobacco control
approach to draw a trauma Zhu Li Bao Zhi
Zhu Li fen simple sake news o town don't
believe in well let's try even ill news
on the point of it in news ago yet he
the news Mizuki who prevails with
territory you will CC avexir me poor the
vast majority the capito damn the post
news Aloha full set fully populated on
the point was a prophecy he regular mode
to the non troppo
massage in la sécurité this is a method
for session later when the criminal with
volunteers Alma and the proprietary
namitha
intimidating global news thank you for
all the time he gave us yesterday on the
black piece profits issue just one last
spring cleaning up
we know the context for the Arabian
Nights event we know the context for the
high school events or performances or
festival what about the video what why
did you do that
what was the context in which she
decided to put on the black face there
what were you doing did you remember
that one and he tell us where that
happened it was a costume day for River
guides on on the on the on the
whitewater rafting in a racking
operation that I that I
in the summer of between 92 and 94
lovely sassy Santino got a posse pon da
de da musica para quitarle yet enkindle
Riga serve an idea connect change only
the is not good morning mr. trudeau
Teresa right from The Canadian Press the
US President Donald Trump has said this
morning that he was surprised to see
images of you wearing blackface and
particularly at the number of times that
you wore it
what kind of an impact do you think that
this is going to have on your
international reputation and how do you
think it'll affect your credibility as a
world leader my focus is on Canadians
who face discrimination every day
Canadians who are racialized who live
within tolerance and marginalization as
part of their daily experience who I
hurt people who in many cases considered
me to be an ally who are deeply hurt by
the terrible choice choices I made many
years ago I apologize deeply to them and
I will focus on continuing what I have
tried to do as a leader which is always
stand against racism and discrimination
at home in on the world stage munafa
robbery at Elizabeth Shue a Canadian you
know in dire tisiphone
discriminate of course our
Anansi de Toledo the jockey and leave
their nightly house
computer shows a very good year kg
blessing havoc mesh watch passing from
an excuse perform Emily
German gosh I've concentrated that her
Nadia in a constant robbery called
metalloids - you see what can I do about
it or not
Prime Minister good morning David yogin
from Reuters your MPs are unhappy your
candidates run happy there are members
of your cabinet by not particularly
happy some members of a cabinet table
who sit around you and have issued long
nazi philosophical statements others
such as your Foreign Minister you should
have fairly clipped three paragraphs
statement yesterday how secure do you
feel in your leadership in the days and
the months and the well days weeks and
months to come
I'm going to continue to stay focused on
working hard for a better Canada and I
know that there are Canadians many many
Canadians that I have deeply hurt with
the choices I made and I am going to
work very very hard to demonstrate that
as a individual and as a leader I will
continue to stand against intolerance
and racism I continue to stand alongside
them as an ally as we strive to build a
better world I let them down I a lot of
people down
[Music]
[Applause]
mr. Trudeau all over the world today
people are on the streets demonstrating
about climate change without going into
a recap of what you've done so far I'd
like to know if you are real ected what
new initiatives what new things would
you do to reduce emissions
I want to begin by celebrating those
young people who are taking to the
streets around the world to highlight
that this is their future this is our
future we are talking about we need to
continue to step up in the fight against
climate change here at home across
Canada and around the world we will have
a lot more to say days and weeks but you
can rest assured that we will continue
in our ambition and our determination to
fight climate change and support
Canadians through this change in our
economy in our world as we protect our
environment and create a better future
for our kids and grandkids silly-willy
rescission key demo
leadership chemo demote kill very fun
axiom kinder con continue the language
confessional climatic CO Canada in fact
we are not I know about the silos of
years for continuing to provide a good
automatic on latisha fair proofs
phonetic able to govern the map or
partition 11 money containers of
mathematics Milman directly among Syrian
citizen developing these called welfare
priests Yeovil Pharisee Giotto the most
colorful at you hi mr. Trudeau David
Cochran with CBC News we've just learned
that your campaign director has reached
out to judgment Singh's campaign
director to arrange a conversation
between the leaders possibly what do you
want to say to mr. Singh after the
events of the last several days I will
be apologizing to him personally as a
racialized Canadian as I have been
apologizing to Canadians who have
suffered discrimination and and
intolerance their entire lives in ways
that some of us like me have never had
to experience on a daily basis this is
an incident for which I am deeply sorry
I have apologized to Canadians but I
have also pledged to continue to work
with all Canadians in the fight against
Islamophobia anti-semitism anti black
racism racism and intolerance in all its
shapes and forms and on that I am
certainly in deep agreement with mr.
Singh and I look forward to having a
good conversation with him Systema BAFTA
G I think mr. Singh needs excuse of a
twig an idea key vivillon Serena
Immokalee Workers a blessing Burmese
action over certain apparently no come
on
cold scenario decontamination visual a
cottagey a the nipples of opportunity
can idea he give let's finish you my
cousin are you don't stay Lucas Martin
you suck that time prime minister will
you confirm that fess is reporting that
according to a high-ranking liberal
official that the campaign the Liberals
are expecting more photos to come out
will you confirm that I have nothing to
confirm on that so there could be more
I have nothing to confirm on there I'm
and just really quickly on guns can you
talk the mayor has talked a lot about
stopping smuggling at the border what
are going to be the actions on there we
are going to we have taken significant
measures to strengthen our border
controls the Conservatives cut the
Canada Border Services Agency in her 10
years in office we have invested
massively in securing our border at to
an increasing degree and we will have
more to say about our plans on that
today our announcement is on how we're
going to be banning military-style
assault weapons and working with
municipalities to restrict handguns
we recognize that there is more to do
that's why liberals believe in
strengthening gun control well
conservers believe in weakening it news
a Volvo codecademy Ozanam poor non-evos
diverse OC Cruiser capacity apology new
Fonterra
des armas ego here guitars - okay - nova
dutra no surveillance you didn't
renounce Akane Tendo / Danielle is and
assumed incorrectly prevents poor
performance penalty and restrain
is Alma found at one Brian Lilly Toronto
Sun mr. Trudeau is there anything else
in your past from your youth before your
time in politics beat at West Point Grey
Academy or anywhere else that you think
Canadians should know about now or that
if you are running for the Liberals for
the first time a vetting committee might
take some real issue with I have been
forthright about the incidents that I
remember as was pointed out I hadn't
remembered the incident on the in the
rafting the rafting company I was
working for and that's why I am worried
about being definitive I did not realize
at the time how much this hurt minority
Canadians racialized Canadians and for
that I am deeply sorry I hurt people who
consider me and have considered me to be
an ally and I will continue to fight
against racism and discrimination with
everything I do is live here but black
face any other type of incidents or
actions not that I can recall
yes I see from loving sister
you apologized immediately after the
black face issue emerged but you haven't
apologized or taking any actions
regarding the SNC leveling scandal some
feminists they were the solution that
because the way you treated into strong
female feminist female ministers and
there they were disappointed that you
you get in the owner your promise to run
a transparent government and to hold the
principle of I think independence of
Judy's judicial review a judicial
independence and so what the actions are
you going to take to convince that this
regime
feminists that us you can be trusted and
to be voted for first of all I recognize
that one of the fundamental jobs of any
Prime Minister is to stand up for the
public interest to stand up for Canadian
jobs and that's exactly what I did and
what I will always do is stand up for
Canadians and their jobs and their
pensions and their communities I will do
that in a way that will and then always
have respected the independent judicial
processes that are core to our
institutions and our democracy that is
why I asked the Honourable and McClellan
to gather recommendations by a broad
range of experts to consult with just
about every living former attorney
general in this country to make
recommendations so that no future
government is in the situation that we
we were in we will continue to stand up
for Canadian jobs we will continue to
respect the independence of our
judiciary and future governments will
have better tools to be able to do that
where you ever a member of any
fraternity while in college that
discriminated and campaigned against
immigration and secondly I couldn't see
any member of the cabinet racialized
community behind you is this a cheesy
and the political campaign as we are
witnessing it today first of all I I was
never
any return 'ti in my university is or
organizations that discriminated against
people might my primary involvement in
clubs in university was both the McGill
debating Union and McGill students has
had the sexual assault center of the
McGill students society where I fought
against and stood against the kind of
challenges that far too many women were
facing around sexual assault and still
continue to face in regards to the
people here today there are many many
great candidates from all sorts of
different backgrounds and sorry
yes marrying is it is here we have a
great team of diverse Canadians who
stepped forward to serve Canada
including in our cabinet and we're going
to continue to make sure that we have
[Applause]
hello anistar the premiere duck for of
Ontario has said that he would have
posed a handgun ban ban on gun sales in
the City of Toronto how would the
liberalism sure that if the city as it
has said it wants to do wants the right
to impose a handgun ban on in the City
of Toronto that it can follow through
with the province imposing we are going
to be working with municipalities across
the country on giving them the ability
to restrict handguns within their city
limits we recognize that there are many
conservatives out there who think we
should be weakening gun control I
disagree
liberals think we need to strengthen gun
control and we need to listen to
municipal leaders like John Tory Vidal
account and others who've been very
clear that they need to keep their
citizens safe by further limiting
handguns in their cities and we will
work with them and with the provinces to
give them something that not just
municipal leaders but many many
Canadians are asking for
[Applause]
and working so effective mark police a
conservator Kievan ethically your
control these are my three the control
is that my field you know the leader the
the budget will conveniently cloudy John
Tory canoes owns infection monkey very
Tootsie Pop of all restraint release on
the point down low miss penalty in news
anchors on the career Baker we have a
clip of a seal it well pour upon I
suppose whether galley no community park
au secours time any conversation is a
set up to be anything
hi Jim we can throw in from cp24 I'd
like to give you an opportunity to
respond to some comments made in an
interview that I conducted with the
co-founder of black lives matter Toronto
I in regards to the photos and video
they say that they were outraged but not
surprised given your track record on
policy relating to race that the apology
was filled with empty words and that the
apology doesn't matter what matters most
is how you will fix race relations like
you to respond to that
obviously I deeply hurt racialized
Canadians and I am deeply sorry for that
I understand the anger and the
frustration of people who everyday face
discrimination face anti black racism
face systemic bias face face unconscious
unconscious bias and systemic
discrimination these are things that our
government has taken significant steps
not just to stand against but to
actually act on whether it was
recognizing the UN decade of people of
African descent and investing twenty
five million dollars over the coming
years so that community organism
patience in the black community can have
the financing funding to continue to
help members of their community whether
it's moving forward on a national anti
racism strategy that includes anti black
racism Islamophobia anti-semitism and
other forms of discrimination and
intolerance we have moved forward in
many different ways of trying to
demonstrate a government that will
consistently and unequivocally stand up
to defend people's rights to defend
people against intolerance and
discrimination but I recognize there is
much much more to do and I recognize it
on a personal level I deeply hurt and
disappointed many people who considered
me to be an ally and for that I am
deeply sorry Missy come on
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]